TO EVERYONE. AND I WILL BE
MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE OUR CENTRAL WORK.
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I'M GOING TO COVER A COUPLE OF
TECHNICAL THINGS- FOR THE DAY
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR THE DAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COBIT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THREE TWO SIX SIX ONE EIGHT
EIGHT AND YOU WILL SEE THAT UP
A FEW MORE TIMES TODAY. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PART. A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY
YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE VERY IMPORTANT THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON.
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND SO WE
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUMDURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. AND WITH
THAT I ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER. WANT TO ASK ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. WE'VE HAD A FEW
GLITCHES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
HEARINGS AND I HAVE.
RESPECTFULLY INTERRUPTED
SPEAKERS TO ASK THEM EITHER TO
SLOW DOWN OR TO START AGAIN
WE'VE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
HEARING DIFFICULTY- AND IF
YOU'LL BEAR WITH US WE'LL GET
IT RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK. AGAIN
THE HEARING PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT AND WE DO WANT TO
HEAR WHAT YOUR COMMENTS ARE SO
IF I INTERRUPT YOU. PLEASE
FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE IT'S ONLY
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HEAR
YOU AND SO THAT OUR COURT
REPORTER WHO'S WORKING VERY
HARD TO RECORD EVERYTHING. HAS
THE ABILITY TO GET YOUR WORDS
ACCURATE SO APPRECIATE THAT.
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- I WILL REMOTE AT LET
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC KNOW THAT
TODAY. SENATOR BATES IS NOT
WITH US AND SENATOR OUGHT GROVE
WILL BE JOINING US SHE- COVERS
TO COMMITTEES ODD TODAY SHE IS
AT THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND SHE
WILL BE JOINING US SHE CAN
MULTI TASK QUITE WELL. SO SHE
WILL BE JOINING US- SO JUST
WANNA LET THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC KNOW THAT. AND TO MY
MEMBERS OF MY COLLEAGUES A
REMINDER YOU'LL NEED TO TURN
YOUR MICROPHONES ON FOR THE
ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME THAT
WE VOTE. AND WITH THAT MA'AM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL OUR
ROLE. GROVE NOW MARKER.
KAMLAGER HERE LAYERED HERE
THEY'RE HERE BATES ABSENT
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE. THANK
YOU HI COLLEAGUES- AS ARE MANY
PEOPLE MAY HAVE NOTICED MANY OF
US IN THE BUILDING TODAY OR
DRESSED MORE CASUALLY THAN
NORMAL WE ALONG WITH PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD ARE WEARING
JEANS AND RECOGNITION OF DENIM
DAY AN ANNUAL DEMONSTRATION OF
OUR ONGOING COMMITMENT TO STAND
FIRM AGAINST SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
TO STAND FIRM WITH SURVIVORS
AND SO AFTER A YEAR IN WHICH WE
SEEN AN UPSETTING RISE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TODAY IS A
REMINDER THAT OUR WORK IS NOT
FINISHED. IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
TIGHT SOMEONE'S GENES ARE OR
HOW LONG WE'VE BEEN ISOLATED AT
HOME NO ONE INVITES ARE
DESERVED TO BE SEXUALLY ASSAULT.
AND IT CERTAINLY NEVER
EXCUSABLE. SO TODAY WE TELL
SURVIVORS THAT YOU ARE SEEN.
YOU ARE BELIEVED AND YOU ARE
NOT ALONE. KILEY SIX FOR.
INDULGING ME AND GIVEN ME A FEW
MINUTES TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT
SPECIAL RECOGNITION THAT WE DO
EVERY YEAR- WITH THAT I AM
GOING TO SEE IF WE CAN. MOVE A
FEW ITEMS AND THE FIRST WOULD
BE BEFORE WE GET TO OUR AUDIT
APPOINTEE DR BOLES WHO'S
WAITING. IN THE WINGS HERE. I
WILL ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
SOMEONE WOULD BE WILLING TO
MOVE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT WOULD
BE ITEM TO BE SUSAN GROUNDS
ALLAH WHO WILL BE A MEMBER OF
THE CONTRACTOR STATE LICENSE
BOARD AMONG. THANK YOU SENATOR
OUR MOTION- MADAM SECRETARY
WILL CALL THE ROLL. REMOVE
MARKER AYE MARGARET AYE LAYERED
AYE THERE'D I. AIDS ABSENT
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE AND THAT
WILL REMAIN ON CALL SO THAT
SENATOR GROWTH CAN EXERCISE HER
BUT WHEN SHE ARRIVES SO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER THREE ART
REFERRAL OF BILLS I THINK WE
HAVE. OUT ONE SEPARATED OUT BUT
REFERENCE OF BILLS MINUS ONE
BILL SB SIXTY FIVE OF WHICH
WILL BE A SEPARATE VOTE WOULD
ASK FOR A MOTION. SENATOR COME
LONGER THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
ROAF KAMLAGER I LONGER I
LAYERED AYE AYE FAITH ATKINS BY
INSIDE ON HOLD WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL AND- I WOULD
HAPPILY TAKE A MOTION TO ALSO
REFER SB SIXTY FIVE. TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
DON'T KNOW SENATOR LAYERED
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL. ROVE MARKER I LONGER I'D
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES
ATKINS. HI CAN SIGN ON CALL TO
BE ON CALL AND MY GOOD
SECRETARY WILL REMIND ME ON
THOSE ON CALL AS WELL AS A WE
HAVE ONE MORE LET ME ASK FOR A
MOTION ON SELECT COMMITTEE
REQUEST AND THIS IS ITEMS FOR.
FIVE SIX AND SEVEN AND IT
BASICALLY EXPANDS AND ADDS
NAMES TO SELECT COMMITTEES THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED
SOME OF. THE AUTHORIZED. YES IN
REGARDS ONE REAL THROW YES.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THE
BACKUP SENATOR OF A HAS MOVED
TO THE ITEM MAN SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL. ROAF KAMLAGER
ALL RIGHT KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI
I BATES ATKINS AYE ATKINS FIVE
AND THAT WILL REMAIN ON CALL
AND WITH THAT- AND AGAIN MA'AM
SECRETARY WILL KERRY WILL
REMIND ME SO I DO NOT FORGET-
WHEN SENATOR GROWTH IS BACK
WITH THAT. I WE WILL NOW TURN
TO OUR GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM ONE
EIGHT AND WELCOME DOCTOR
HAVEN'T HEATHER BOLTS AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. LET US SAY
WELCOME TO YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AS WE GET UNDER
WAY WANT TO INVITE YOU TO I
INTRODUCED YOURSELF ANYONE WITH
YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. AND ALSO TO MAKE
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND AFTER
YOUR INTRODUCTION WILL GO
STRAIGHT TO MEMBERS FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. WELCOME
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON I
WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
ALTHOUGH MY FAMILY IS NOT WITH
ME TODAY I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK MY
PARENTS WHO'VE ALWAYS SUPPORTED
ME NO MATTER HOW FAR AWAY
MICHAELS TOOK ME FROM WHERE I
GREW UP MY HUSBAND WHO FOLLOWED
ME TO CALIFORNIA SO THAT I CAN
GET MY DOCTORATE THIS SUPPORT
IS NEVER WAVERED EVENING EVEN
WHEN I WAS THE COLLUDED IN A
ROOM FINALIZING MY DISSERTATION
OR BURIED IN MY RESEARCH ABOUT
TREATMENT PROGRAM. AND MY
CHILDREN KEEP ME GROUNDED AND
REMIND ME EVERY DAY HOW
IMPORTANT THIS WORK IS. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE DJJ FAMILY FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO OUR MISSION.
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
CHALLENGING PAST YEAR. I
STARTED WORKING AS A
PSYCHOLOGICAL IN TERMS OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHEN IT
WAS STILL THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY. I WALKED IN
EXPECTING TO GAIN SOME
EXPERIENCE FIRST SEMESTER BUT
INSTEAD DISCOVERED MY LIFE'S
PASSION. IT WAS THE USE AND THE
CHANCE TO HELP SUPPORT THEM
TOWARDS A BETTER FUTURE THAT
RESONATED SO STRONGLY WITH ME.
THROUGHOUT MY YEARS AT DJJ I'VE
BEEN AFFORDED MANY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT HAVE ALLOWED
ME TO TAKE POSITIONS I NEVER
EXPECTED. AND THEY GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP SHAPE
PROGRAM PROGRAMMING AND LOOK
FOR BETTER WAYS TO PROVIDE
TREATMENT. THAT IS WHY I'VE
STAYED WITH DJJ FOR SO MANY
YEARS. GOVERNOR NEWSOMHAS
HONORED ME WITH THE
APPOINTMENTS A WEEK JJJ AND
THIS TIME OF HISTORIC
REALIGNMENT OF SERVICES TO YOU.
I TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY WITH
HUMILITY AND COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT OUR YOUTH WITH QUALITY
TREATMENT AND SERVICE DELIVERY.
ADMIN DOWNSIZING OUR OPERATIONS
TO SUPPORT OUR STAFF AS WE
NAVIGATE CLOSURE. AS WELL AS
BEING ACTIVE AND COLLABORATIVE
PARTNER WITH OUR STATE AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS AS A
STREAMLINED CARS. ALTHOUGH MY
TENURE IN THIS POSITION WILL BE
SHORT. I APPLIED FOR AN
ACCEPTED THIS POSITION BECAUSE
I CARE ABOUT THE. AND I CARE
ABOUT THE STAFF WHO SERVES THEM.
IT MATTERS TO ME HOW WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE AS WE CLOSE
TO J. J. AND WITH THAT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR I'M
GONNA START SENATOR LAYERED
WITH YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR ARM.
AND THANK YOU ARE A DOCTOR FOR.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND I
APPRECIATED THE MEETING WE HAD
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT. YOU DON'T HAVE A MORE
TRADITIONAL PATH TO THIS
POSITION AND IT GIVES YOU. HI
DISCOVERED A PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL. I THINK THE ONE
THING I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS
INTERESTINGLY YOU'RE ACCEPTING
THIS JOB. TO HELP ORGANIZE YOUR
JOB OUT OF EXISTENCE A. N. SO
IN DOING THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
YEARS. AND YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
CHALLENGES YOU HAVE YOU HAVE TO
CONTINUE CERTAIN CASES. PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO START TO LOOK FOR
OTHER JOBS AND YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO HOLD PEOPLE THERE TILL
THE END BECAUSE THE CASES DON'T
GO AWAY AS THE TRANSITION
HAPPENS. BY A YEAR YOU AND I
TALKED PRIVATELY ABOUT THIS I
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A GOOD
THING FOR YOU TO TALK ABOUT. IN
PUBLIC IS HOW YOU'RE PREPARED
TO MEET THAT CHALLENGE IS
WINDING THIS DOWN. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY- SO YOU'RE CORRECT
IN THAT- YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A
CHALLENGE AHEAD OF US OVER
THESE NEXT TWO YEARS BUT- I
KNOW THAT WE CAN FACE IT. HEAD
ON- SO WHEN WE START LOOKING AT
HOW WE MAP UT THESE NEXT TWO
YEARS THERE'S A COUPLE OF.
IMPORTANT TIME FRAMES AND
DATES. THAT HELPED DRIVE- WHAT
WE NEED TO DO AS WELL AS IMPORT
COMPONENTS OF WHAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO. FOR YOU OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. THE FIRST-
THE KEY DATE THAT WE THAT.
IMPACTS HOW WE START THIS IS
COMMITMENTS TO DJJ. AND WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF A SMALL GROUP.
AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT INTO HOW WE START
MAPPING OUT THESE NEXT TWO
YEARS IS THAT- DJJ HAS-
PROGRAMMING DEVELOPED TO MEET.
USE UNIQUE INDIVIDUAL MEANS WE
DO ASSESSMENT WHEN THEY COME IN
WE HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PROGRAMS THAT MATCH. THEIR
NEEDS AS WELL AS SOME
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE THEN THE WHOLE PROGRAM
THAT ADDRESS- OTHER TREATMENT
NEEDS. AND SO IT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO ASSESS AND TAKE A LOOK
AT FULLY. WHO WILL BE COMING TO
US OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS-
IT. AND HE WILL BE SENTENCED TO
DJJ WHAT THEIR TREATMENT NEEDS
ARE AND WHERE DOES OUR ULTIMATE
NUMBERS LIFE AND NOT THEN HOW
WE START LOOKING AT. AS OUR
POPULATION DECLINES WHAT NEEDS
TO THE REMAINING POPULATION
HAVE. WHAT PROGRAMS DO WE NEED
TO HAVE UP AND RUNNING HOW DOES
THAT IMPACT- HOW WE START TO
TAKE DOWN CERTAIN UNITS- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE TIME FRAMES.
FOR DISABILITIES- DATE BIG. AND
MOST IMPORTANT PART OF ALL OF
THIS IS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE CARE FOR OUR YEARS.
UNTIL THE VERY LAST DAY. AND SO
ONCE WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
TREATMENT NEEDS ARE YOU HAVE
BEEN THERE'S IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS- AROUND HOW DO WE
MAINTAIN THAT TREATMENT. AND
LEVEL OF CARE AS AGAIN WE START
TO DOWNSIZE SO THAT INVOLVES
LOOKING AT- AS OUR NUMBERS GO
DOWN ON THE FOR EXAMPLE I
MENTAL HEALTH UNIT. WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE SERVICES ON OUR
MENTAL HEALTH UNIT TO THE LAST
DAY- NO MATTER IF IT. FIVE TEN
YEARS OR FIVE YEARS. SO HOW DO
WE PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES ON
WHAT. MODELS BUT YOU KNOW HOW
DO WE- MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CAN
STAND WITH OUR MODEL BUT
ADAPTING THINGS AS WE- WE
DOWNSIZED- WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT ALTERNATIVES. AS AS
YOU MENTIONED AND I WANT TO
TALK MORE ABOUT- IN JUST A
MOMENT IS- OUR STAFFING- WHO-
YOU KNOW WE DO YOU HAVE.
VACANCY RATES AND- WE ARE
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO. YOU WHAT
WE CAN IN TERMS OF RECRUITMENT
ENTERTAINMENT BUT- THAT IS ALSO
GOING TO BE A VITAL AS WE MAP
OUT. HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES- THAT
LEADS TO MORE CONVERSATION THAT
YOU KNOW AGAIN THAT SECOND
COMPONENT- WITH OUR STAFF. I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR
OUR STAFF OUR GREATEST RESOURCE
AND VITAL TO THE TREATMENT THAT
WE PROVIDE. I RELY ON MY STAFF
TO PROVIDE CARE AND SUPPORT TO
OUR YOUTH. WHICH IS GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS WE
DOWNSIZE AND THERE'S QUESTIONS
COMING UP ABOUT NEXT STEPS YOU
WILL HAVE. AND SO IN TURN I
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PROVIDING CARE AND SUPPORT TO
OUR STAFF. AND SO I'M COMMITTED
TO DOING EVERYTHING I CAN TO
HELP THEM. NAVIGATE THE CLOSURE
PROCESS AND SEE THEMTRANSITION
INTO NEW ROLES BY WORKING WITH
YOU KNOW OUR LABOR LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND CALLIE CHART
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE. AFFORDED
EVERY OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE- AS
WELL AS OPEN COMMUNICATION
AROUND THE TIME FRAMES THAT I
TALKED ABOUT ORIGINALLY BECAUSE
THAT'S ALSO IN PART TO THE
QUESTION NOT ONLY ARE YOU HAVE
THAT OUR STAFF HAVE ABOUT.
WHAT'S. HAPPENING WITH THE
UNITS AND FACILITIES- ONE OF
THE OTHER BIGGEST COME THAT WE
NEED TO WILL BE TACKLING IS
THEN FOR USE THAT- THE PROPOSED
CLOSURE DATE FOR DJJ IS JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE- THERE IS A TRANSITION
PLAN THAT WILL BE DO AS- BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO
WITH OUR POPULATION WE NEED TO
ASSESS WHO. ARE YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO DISCHARGE FROM US BY
THAT JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DAY. AND SO WHAT
WILL THAT PROCESS BE THAN TO
TRANSFER THEM BACK INTO LOCAL
CARE. AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THIS IS A CONVERSATION
THAT. WE NEED TO INCLUDE OUR
PARTNERS AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA- THAT
COUNTIES. THE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS- IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
LOOK AT WHAT THAT PROCESS IS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY. THAT EACH
OF OUR YOUTH AS I AS I
MENTIONED HAVE VERY UIQUE
NEEDS AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TRANSITION WE NEED TO REALIZE
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REENTRY IS A PART
DISCHARGED. THIS IS A TRANSFER
OF CARE WHICH MEANS WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK CASE BY CASE OUT
WHAT EACH OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
EITHER NAME- AND WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS ON HOW WE THEN MAKE
SURE THERE'S A CONTINUUM OF
CARE. FOR WHATEVER THOSE NEEDS
ARE FOR EXAMPLE GOING BACK TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH EXAMPLE- THAT
LEVEL OF CARE WOULD NEED TO
CONTINUE. AND SO I VALUE THE
PARTNERSHIPS- WITH ALL OF THOSE
AGENCIES AND THE WORK THAT AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY HAD TOWARDS HOW WE
START TO MAP THIS OUT. WE ARE
ALL FOCUSED ON THE GOAL OF
MAKING SURE THAT THESE ARE
CARED FOR IN THAT TRANSITION
OCCURS. WHEN THINGS POSSIBLE-
SO THAT THAT IS AGAIN A LARGE
COMPONENT OF WHERE WE NEED TO-
MAPPED OUT AND WHEN WE START
FACING THOSE THINGS AND YOU
KNOW I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ABOUT HOW
YOU JUST BALANCE. THE WINDING
DOWN OF PEOPLE LOOKING FOR
OTHER JOBS AND HAVING TO
CONTINUE THE CARE TO THE LAST
DAY BUT YOU JUST ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION VERY WELL SO LET ME
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER
I APPRECIATED AND I APPRECIATE
THE DIFFICULTY. THAT IT'S GOING
2% BUT ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
GOING TO BE VERY COMFORTABLE
VOTING TO CONFIRM YOU LATER AS
YOU SEEM TO BE ON TOP OF IT YOU
SEEM TO RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE
ARE THE ISSUES YOU'RE GOING TO
FACE OVER THE NEXT. TWO YEARS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR. I CENTER GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRETENDING AND
AM THINKING MISSILES FOR-
TAKING ON THE CHALLENGES MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR LAIRD SAID-
FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS WHILE
THEY CLOSE DOWN THE DJJ SYSTEM
AND- YOU HAVE A BIG JOB IN
FRONT OF THE LIKE HE SAID TO
KEEP STAFF AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT- ED THESE INDIVIDUALS GET
PUT IN A FACILITIES IN THE
COUNTY LEVEL THAT ARE- THE MORE
THAN ADEQUATE ADD TO MEET THE
NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE. SO I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
WHAT COORDINATION DIFFERENCES
DJJ ESTABLISHING TO ENSURE
COUNTIES ARE PROPERLY PREPARED
TO HOUSE EDUCATE AND PROVIDE
TREATMENT FOR THESE YOUTH
RETURNED TO THE CUSTODY. TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS DJJ CLOSES.
REASON WHY I ASK THIS. IS
BECAUSE JUSTIN BUDGET A FEW
MINUTES AGO EARLIER TODAY WE
HEARD THE BUDGET BILL AND THAT
BILL ACTUALLY HAD TWO DATES
THAT WERE SIGNIFICANT. THE JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE DATE
THAT SAYS COUNTIES HAVE TO BE
READY AND HAVE- EITHER HAVE
BUILT FACILITIES OR ESTABLISH A
PLACE FOR THESE. THESE YOU'VE
TO GO. AND THEN IT ALSO SAID
THAT ON JULY EIGHTH HE'S ME
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FOR THAT DATE IN JULY TWENTY
FIRST HE'S ME JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR THE
SECOND DAY WHICH IS THE SAME
DATE. THAT THE GUIDELINES WOULD
BE ESTABLISHED SOME A LITTLE
CONCERNED HOW PEOPLE WOULD WORK
TOGETHER ON THE GROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE. AND YOU'D HAVE
A PLACE TO GO THAT MEET THE
GUIDELINES BUT YET THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO HAVE IT READY BY
THE TIME THE GUIDELINES ARE
ESTABLISHED. ON THE SAME DATE.
SO IN TERMS OF- MY ROLE IN DJS
FAULT IS ONE WE WILL WE NEED TO
BE AND I'M COMMITTED TO BEING
AN ACTIVE PARTNER AND BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION AND DATA- SHEREEN
AROUND. OUR PROGRAMMING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP I'M I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING THIS WITH- BOTH WITH.
THE CAR- AS A PART OF THE-
OFFICE OF YOU THINK HOW MANY
RESTORATION HELPFUL FOR
COUNSEL- THAT BORDER STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY AT
THERE'S ALSO A COUNCIL OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH UNIT TOOL KITS FOR THIS
SO WE'VE BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS- AND-
AGAIN BEING ABLE TO BEAT
WHATEVER RESOURCE WE HAVE WE
CAN PROVIDE WE CAN GIVE- BE A
PART OF ANY CONVERSATIONS THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. TO HELP MAKE
THIS REALIGNMENT SUCCESSFUL- IT
I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
ULTIMATELY THOSE ARE LOCAL
DECISIONS THAT WILL BE MADE IN
TERMS OF THE DETAILS OF HOW
THIS WORKS BOB BUT OUR ROLE IS
BECAUSE YOU GET TO BE A ACTIVE
PARTNER IN DOING WHATEVER WE
CAN TO HELP MAKE SURE. THAT CAN
HAPPEN ANY. I AM THANK YOU YOU
MUCH- I AM NEXT QUESTION I HAVE
REGARDING. DATA YOU KNOW M. HOW
DO YOU VIEW THE REESE'S IT
RECIDIVISM DATA IN RESPECT TO-
INTEGRATED BEHAVIOR TREATMENT
MODELS AND- I GUESS IT'S BEEN
ROLLED OUT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND I WANT TO FIND OUT IF
THERE IS- A BELIEVE THAT
RECIDIVISM RATES ARE BETTER.
AND REFLECT BETTER OUTCOMES NOW
BECAUSE OF THAT ROLL OUT- I
THINK I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION I HAVE- ONE THING I
WILL SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE
CHALLENGE WITH RECIDIVISM DATA
IS ALWAYS THAT. YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW A COURT FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS USUALLY FIVE YEARS TO
THEN BE ABLE TO LOOK AT. THOSE
RECIDIVISM RATES AND SO ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD A DJ
IN TERMS OF THOSE QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THE IBM MODEL- AN
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. ARE THAT
THE RECIDIVISM OUTCOMES WE-
THAT THE LAST REPORT WAS
PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN. IT WAS AT THIRTEEN
THE- TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. TO
FOURTEEN I'M SORRY YOU THOUSAND
FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN CO COURT
AND SO EVEN THAT COHORT WAS NOT
YET A COHORT THAT HAD GONE
THROUGH ALL OF THE COMPONENTS
AT THE END OF THE IV TìM. SO
WITNESS RECIDIVISM DATA THIS
PARTICULAR YEAR- IT WAS YOU
KNOW- SAID THREE YEAR
CONVICTION RATE WAS. AROUND 50%
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY WE WANT BETTER
THAN THAT- AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAD DONE- ROUND
I BELIEVE IT WAS. THAT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MAYBE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN IS- ALSO
WORK WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
IRVINE. YOU NOT ONLY LOOK AT
HOW WELL THE BABY TìM IS
WORKING IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM
RATES BUT CAN WE LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT OF RECIDIVISM
PERCENTAGE DOESN'T TELL ME IS
FOR THOSE THAT RECENT EVADED.
WHY WAS THERE A COMMON REASON
WHAT PROGRAMMING THAT THEY
RECEIVE WHAT RISK LEVELS THAT
THEY HAVE DID WE HELP DECREASE
THOSE RISKS LEVELS SO WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE UNIVERSITY
YEAR IRVINE ON. A MULTI FACETED
THAT STUDY TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THOSE COMPONENTS AS WELL SO
THEIR INITIAL ONE WAS TO DO
THAT PROGRAM EVALUATION- AND
THAT WAS- PUBLISHED IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY- STATE THAT
RECOGNIZE THAT IT APPEARED THAT
THE IV TìM WAS. AN EVIDENCE
BASED MODEL- BEAR WITH THE USED
AS THAT THEY HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT
THE STAFF BELIEVED IN THE MODEL
THE VIEWS STATED THAT THEY FELT
THEY WERE GETTING THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY NEEDED AT ALL
DIFFERENT SERVICE LEVELS. THERE
WERE- SUGGESTIONS THAT THEY
MADE FOR NEXT STEPS IN TERMS OF
THE FIDELITY AND STAFFING.
MAKING SURE STAFFING VACANCIES
RUBBER. PART OF THAT BUT- I
THINK THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT PURSUE. AND VALUE.
THE WHETHER A PROGRAM ON A LIST.
THANK THAT'S VERY GOOD- I JUST
CAN I CLARIFY ON THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU GAVE ME YOU HAD A
FIFTY PERCENT- RECIDIVISM RATE
WAS NOT ON THE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
NUMBERS OR WAS THAT ON THE-
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN NUMBER EARTH.
ALL FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN OKAY SO THE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN NUMBER SHOULD COME OUT
I'M PRETTY SOON- WHEN DOES THAT
REPORT EXPECT TO BE RELEASED-
I. AM NOT- I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE BUT THAT IS SOMETHING WE
COULD BUY COULD FIND OUT FOR
YOU. OKAY GREAT STATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME ASK
THESE QUESTIONS I DO- I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW IF AGAIN. IN THE
REAL WORLD I'M A JOB CREATOR
RIGHT I THINK A JOB IS THE BEST
SOLUTION FOR PROPERTY OR
SOMEBODY TO STAY OUT OF TROUBLE
OR STAFF THE STREETS OR-
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES I
MEAN YOU NAME IT THE JOB IS AN
ANSWER IN. AN M. IT WAS YEARS
AGO BUT WE FORMED AN ALLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL OFFICE IN THE COMMANDER-
IN BAKERSFIELD. A LOUDEST USE A
CHP OFFICER ONE HOUR A WEEK TO
MENTOR- AT RISK YOUTH THAT CAME
FROM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE IT WAS
ACTUALLY PRETTY INTERESTING
PROGRAM THAT WE DID- AND THE
REASON WHY I BRING IT UP IS
BECAUSE THOSE GROUP DOES USE
THAT WENT THROUGH IT NOW.
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED GOING
TO THE PROGRAM. I WITHOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH C. H. P. WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES- THAT COMMUNITY AS- THE
COMMUNITY THAT COMES FROM THAT
TYPE OF AREA AND THAT-
ENVIRONMENT. AND BEING IN
PRISON DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF-
OR THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS
AND A LOT OF POSITIVE INTERTEK
INTERACT AND WITH THE POLICE
OFFICERS. INTO THIS GAVE THE
POLICE OFFICERS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MENTOR. TEACH YOU KNOW SPEND
TIME WITH THEM M. GET TO KNOW
THEIR LIFESTYLE AND WHO THEY
ARE AND WHERE THEY CAME FROM
AND- AND THEN TO SHOW THESE USE
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING BETTER
OUT THERE THAN WHAT THEY'RE-
DOING. ON THE STREET OR GET
DOING TO GET INTO IT DO YOU
KNOW JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND THEN
IT WAS A GREAT SUCCESS AND I
HATED TO SEE THAT PROGRAM GO
AWAY- BUT IT DID- AND IONLY
BRING IT UP BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
YESTERDAY THAT I GOT A TEXT
MESSAGE FROM AN INDIVIDUAL THAT
WAS SHARING WITH ME THAT HE'S
MARRIED NOW AND HAVING A BABY.
AND HE WAS ONE OF THE ONES THAT
WE WERE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THAT WAS GOING TO RESET YOU
KNOW. GO BACK TO YOU. THAT AND
HE'S- DOING VERY VERY WELL SO
IT JUST MADE ME THINK THAT IT'S
JUST IRONIC THAT YOUR
CONFIRMATION OR IS IT TODAY
AND- I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND I KNOW YOU PROBABLY
WANT AROUND WHEN THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED BUT- I THINK WE NEED
TO GO BACK TO PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT. BECAUSE THE KIDS LEARNED
A LOT. I MEAN WE SEE. ONE HOPE
TO LESSER WAS CONSTRUCTION.
BUILDER A BUILDER OF HOMES AND-
AND THEN. YOU KNOW YOU JUST
THINK THAT WHEN YOU WORK WITH.
WILL PEOPLE KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU MEAN AND HE SAID THE
KID IS GOING TO BE THAT IMPACT
WRENCH. IN THE KID WENT TO THE
TRACK FOR LIKE TEN MINUTES IN
THE SPEECH PAVE SIR GOT A
LITTLE FRUSTRATED WHATEVER GOES
WHAT'S MATTER. AND THE KID IS
FRANTICALLY. TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IN GOOGLE WHAT IMPACT
WRENCHES RIGHT AND FIND IT WITH
ALL THE TOOLS IN THE BACK. AND
THEN THE OFFICERS TOOK IT A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME EXPLAINED
ALL THAT PROCESS AND WHAT THESE
WORDS AND THEY KIND OF DID A
QUIZ TEST NAY. DID SOME
DRAWINGS ON WHERE THE TOOLS ARE
STORED IN SO. AND THAT'S THAT
YOUNG MAN IS NOW LEAD MECHANIC
FOR ONE OF THE OIL FIELD
SERVICE SUPPORTERS COMPANIES
THAT WE HAVE IN KERN COUNTY SO.
I THINK IT WAS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AND- I THINK
THAT WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
YOUTH DON'T RE OFFEND. THEY
DON'T GO BACK TO THE- SAME
PLACE WITH THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT. AND IF THEY DO GO BACK
THEN THEIRSTAND THEY STRONG
STAND ENOUGH THIS STRONG. SENSE
WRONGNESS. TO AND SAY I'M
TEASING A NEW PATH NOW SO. I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH
SENATOR COME LONGER THANK YOU
AT MADAME PRO TEM IT'S GOOD. TO
SEE YOU AGAIN AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR GIVE ME SOME OF YOUR
TIME. OF OTHER DAY TO MEET WITH
YOU- AND TO TALK WITH YOU AND
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT YOUR
HISTORY- MY COLLEAGUES ASKED
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
ASKED YOU WHEN WE TALKED I
THINK IT'S AMAZING THAT SOMEONE
IS GETTING APPOINTED TO
ESSENTIALLY CLOSE OUT THEIR
JOB. BUT MORE POWER TO YOU AND
I THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
AN EXCELLENT SELECTION- IN YOU
FOR THIS APPOINTMENT I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT- BUT I THINK THAT
THEY'RE REALLY IMPORTANT AND
JUST WANT YOU TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY ON THE
RECORD TO SHARE WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN DOING. AND YOUR THOUGHTS
WE KNOW THAT- DJ J. HAS
INVESTED IN THE GIRLS UNIT WE
KNOW THAT A NUMBER OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN DJJ OUR YOUNG GIRLS
AND THEY'RE ALSO YOUNG MOTHERS-
AND WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU COULD
JUST SHARE SORT OF ON AVERAGE
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK THAT
NUMBER IS- AND- HOW ARE THESE
YOUNG MOTHERS AND I GUESS YOUNG
FATHERS TO. BUT HOW ARE THE
YOUNG MOTHERS REALLY
ACCOMMODATED- IN DJJ I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO KIND
OF SEE THEM AS YOU NO FULL-
BEANS AND- IN SOME INSTANCES
WITH ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE NOT REALLY THINKING
ABOUT- BECAUSE MANY OF US MIGHT
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT DO YOU SAY IS RIGHT NOW
THE END UP THERE SO. WOULD LOVE
TO HEAR- YOUR- RESPONSE- TO HOW
DO YOU JJ'S ACCOMMODATING ARE
YOUNG MOTHERS. SURE SO- IN IN
TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION AROUND
AROUND THE NUMBERS WE DON'T
HAVE A DATABASE THAT TRACKS-
THE NUMBERS AROUND HOW MANY OF
OUR YOUTH THEIR PARENTS BUT-
IMPORTANT PIECE IS THAT THAT
WOULD BE IDENTIFIED AS A PART
OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT
PLANS. IN TERMS OF ANYTHING
THAT THEY NEEDED TO WORK ON-
WITH NOT ONLY THAT FAMILY
DYNAMIC BUT SUPPORT AND- HOW DO
YOU THINK THROUGH PARENTING
SKILLS- YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU.
ANY FEARS THAT ARE THAT ARE YOU
HAVE ALL OF THOSE THINGS WOULD
BE IDENTIFIED IN TERMS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT PLAN- FOR
OUR OUR OUR YOUNG WOMEN- YOU
KNOW PEOPLE WOULD WANT ME TO
GET A STEP BACK AND SAY- WE
HAVE DONE A LOT OF WORK- OUR
STAFF BUT THEN HER ARE
FANTASTIC AND WORKING WITH OUR
GIRLS. AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING GENDER
RESPONSIVE- RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF NEEDING TO FOCUS
ON TRAUMA AND RELATIONSHIPS AND
HISTORY OF HELPING YOU- THANKS
FOR ALL OF THOSE I PREFERENCE
THAT YOUR QUESTION WITH THAT
BECAUSE ALL OF THAT ALSO FEEDS
INTO- MAKING SURE THAT WE'VE
GOT FAMILY CONNECTIONS THAT OUR
USERS ARE CONNECTED TO THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY.
THIS PASTOR KOBE DID WAS A
CHALLENGE TERMS OF FACE TO FACE
VISITS BUT VIRTUAL THEN THAT'S
AND BEING ABLE TO STAY
CONNECTED TO YOU- THEIR
CHILDREN WHO THEIR- HE'S TAKING
CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN AND SO
THAT ARE ALL IN EACH SITUATION
IS UNIQUE SO I GO BACK TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT PLAN IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH EACH OF OUR PARENTS ON-
YOU KNOW WHAT THE SITUATION IS
WHAT THE PLANS ARE AS THEY GO
BACK TO YOU- HAD TOWARDS.
REENTRY AND DISCHARGE- ARE THEY
GOING BACK TO BE AN ACTIVE
PARENT IS IT GOING TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE AND HOW DO YOU
WORK THROUGH THOSE THINGS SO I
WOULDN'T I WOULD SAY OVERALL
THAT'S HOW WE ADDRESS IT IS
REALLY TAKING A LOOK AT EACH OF
THOSE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND HOW
DO WE BEST SUPPORT ARE YOU. IN
BECOMING STRONG PARENTS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I WE ALSO TO
ABOUT- THE SEXUAL BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT PROGRAM- THAT- IS
OPERATED THERE AND- YOU KNOW I
HAVE SUCH CONCERNS ABOUT OUR
ARMED- AT PRISON PIPELINE I
HAVE HUGE CONCERNS ABOUT- ARE
OF A SEX REGISTRY AND THE EASE
WITH WHICH WE LIKE TO LABEL
FOLK SEXUAL OFFENDERS IN THE
STATE MOM THAT'S- REALLY
ATTRIBUTED TO THEM AND- I ALSO
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT A GOOD
NUMBER OF THOSE FOLKS HAVE ALSO
BEEN VICTIMIZED OFTENTIMES
VICTIMIZED- DURING THEIR YOUTH-
SEXUALLY VICTIMIZED. WHICH
LEADS TO SOME OF THE- BEHAVIOR
THAT THEY END UP- BEING
INVOLVED IN AND- YOU KNOW
ACTIVATING AND SO- WOULD LOVE
TO SORT OF HAVE YOU SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- YOU KNOW THE
FOLKS THAT ARE IN THERE THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THEIR-
WHO MIGHT BE LABELED- SEX
OFFENDERS AND- THE WORK THAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THAT. THAT ON
THE SEXUAL BEHAVIOR TREATMENT-
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- AS WE
TALK ABOUT REHABILITATION AS WE
TALK ABOUT SORT OF RE ENTRY AS
WE TALK ABOUT THE HEALING- BUT
ALSO AS WE TALK ABOUT LIKE DE
STIGMATIZING AND CREATING
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS- FOR FOLKS
TO BE- RECEIVED AND VIEWED-
THIS IS IT'S SOMETHINGTHAT'S
VERY HARD TO- HI- NOT BE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT HAS LIFE
LONG IMPLICATIONS- AND- I. SO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT BUT
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO SHARE. A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- THAT PROGRAM
AND HOW THAT'S BEEN AFFECTED
FOR THE YOUNG FOLKS. ABSOLUTELY
AND THIS IS. A PROGRAM THAT'S
VERY VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART- I
WORKED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS-
ALONG WITH OUR STAFF TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING THE
TREATMENT THAT WAS APPROPRIATE
TO THIS POPULATION- I FIRST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND I THINK
IT'S- ALSO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE OF THEM.
WHAT WAS THAT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR AND
THAT- YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AND DIFFICULT TOPIC-
TO DISCUSS BECAUSE IT DOES
TRIGGER A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EMOTIONS AND INDIVIDUALS FOR
MANY DIFFERENT REASONS. AND SO
I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WHEN
WE'RE DISCUSSING THE TREATMENT
THAT THE ISSUE FOR ME THAT- IT
AND OF YOU TO HAVE IT WITH
SEXUAL ABUSE OF BEHAVIOR- IT'S
NOT INTENDEDTO MINIMIZE THE
HARM EXPERIENCED BY THE
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ABUSE. AND
THESE CRIMES AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW THE BEHAVIORS THAT
OCCURRED SO- I JUST NEEDED TO
SAY THAT FROM THE BEGINNING-
WHEN WE DEVELOPED A SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT PROGRAM AND
THIS WAS- WE IMPLEMENTED THE
NEW CURRICULUM IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE SO I I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT I WANTED KNOWLEDGE TO YOU
AS A- IN A FIELD WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY FROM WHEN I FIRST
STARTED. RESEARCHING THIS AND
LOOKING AT YOU YOU KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE FOR EACH YEAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
JUVENILES WHO HAVE- WITH
SEXUALLY ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR IS
THAT THEY ARE NOT- THEY NEED TO
BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY. THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RISKS- THAT
YOUR ADULT OFFENDERS DO THEIR
DIFFERENT RISKS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE RECIDIVISM RATE
FOR SEXUAL OFFENSES IS LOW FOR
THIS POPULATION SO- FOR YEARS
THE FIELD HAS- THAT. REVAMPS
I'VE FOUND THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND RESEARCH BOTH THEM
THROUGH SINGLE RESEARCH AS WELL
AS MATT AND ALICE'S THAT
TYPICALLY THIS POPULATION WILL
RE OFFENSE ACTUALLY AROUND
SIXTY EIGHT PERCENT. AND IN
YOUR RESEARCH IS EVEN SAYING
WITH TREATMENT IT'S PRETTY
SOUND TO SAY 5% SO WHAT THAT
TELLS US IS THESE ARTS LIFELONG
BEHAVIORS THESE ARE TREATABLE
THE ACRES AND IT MAKES SENSE IN
TERMS OF THEIR ADOLESCENCE
THEIR GROWING THEY'RE CHANGING.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS
WHAT YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
WITH THIS POPULATION IS MAKE
SURE YOU'RE TARGETING THE RIGHT
TREATMENT. BECAUSE. ONE THERE
IS SUCCESS AND THEN YOU'RE ALSO
HELPING THE END OF THE UNDER
WHAT WILL TO THE- EIGHT YEARS.
STAND THERE THINKING AND WHAT
LED THEM TO THOSE OFFENSES
RECOGNIZING THAT CONVERSATIONS
AROUND HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
AND HEALTHY SEXUALITY IS HUGE.
AND I EVEN WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT I THINK THAT CONTINUES TO
BE IMPORTANT. NOT ONLY FOR THE
POPULATION WHO IS COMING TO OUR
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR TREATMENT
PROGRAM BUT FOR ADOLESCENTS IN
GENERAL SOCIAL MEDIA ACCESS TO
INTERNET PORN. HAS ALTERED.
KIND OF HOW CELEBRATE THESE
YOUNGER GENERATIONS ARE
THINKING ABOUT. WHAT'S HEALTHY
AND THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE NEEDS
TREATMENT PROGRAMS- AS WELL AS
RECOGNIZING BECOMING FROM A
STRING FACE TO BE ABLE TO. HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE
ABILITIES TO OVER COME THIS TO
BE ABLE TO. WORK THROUGH THESE
THOMAS TO ALSO UNDERSTAND. AND
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THE IMPACT OF
HOW THEY IMPACT AND- YOU KNOW
AFFECTED THEIR VICTIMS- WOULD
BE WHICH IS ALSO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. SO OVERALL I THINK
I'D SAY THAT THE PROGRAM THAT
WE PUT IN A PLACE REALLY
EMPHASIZED BEING ABLE TO.
DEVELOP A HEALTHY LIFE. AND
BECOME HEALTHY ADULTS- AND
THEN- IN GENERAL I'LL JUST I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT WITH ST AND I
HAVE TO PULL IT IS BECAUSE THIS
IS AN AREA AYE. AYE I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN FOR SO MUCH I HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS. I
COULD GO ON AND ON. BUT BUT
OVERALL JUST LEAVE IT WITH. YOU
KNOW. RECOGNITION OF. OF THIS
IS A VERY AT. THESE ARE
TREATABLE BEHAVIORS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO THAT AND TO
PROVIDE THE RIGHT TREATMENT
BECAUSE BY DOING THAT IS HOW
HELP. PREVENT. ASSAULTS IN THE
FUTURE. YOU KNOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH I WHEN WE TALK I TELL YOU
I WAS GOING TO THE- AND YOU DID
SAY THAT THAT YOU WERE EXCITED
ABOUT THIS ONE BECAUSE- IT IS
SO CLOSE TO YOUR HEART AND WHAT
YOU DO SO I JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD- AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL IN YOUR
HOLISTIC RESPONSES IN YOUR-
HOLISTIC APPROACH. TO THIS
WORK- I THANK YOU FOR SEEING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AS YOU HAS
CHILDREN YOU KNOW AND NOT AS
PREDATORS THEY ARE DEFINITELY
YOUNG FOLKS THAT HAVE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE ISSUES
REAL ISSUES. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE SEE CHILDREN
AS CHILDREN. IN THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- AND YOU KNOW
THE LANDS AT THE LEADERSHIP
LEVEL IS SO KEY. AND I THINK
YOUR LANDS IS THE APPROPRIATE
ONE. FOR THIS POSITION AND I AM
VERY HAPPY- TO SUPPORT YOU FOR
THIS APPOINTMENT AND I REALLY
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE BROUGHT TO THIS JOB. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE INCREDIBLE
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS IDEA OF
YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE GONE DOWN
THE SAME TRACK. THE ONLY THING
I TRULY HOPE IS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TALKED WITH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH SERVICES ABOUT.
TRANSITIONING YOUNG PEOPLE
DIFFERENT CATEGORY DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS BUT TRANSITIONING
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM OUT OF STATE
BACK IN STATE AND MAKE IT TO
THE KEY IS ALWAYS MAKING SURE
THE SERVICES EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE AND- YOU KNOW
LISTENING TO YOU I AND IN YOUR
VISION I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES- YOU ARE
OBVIOUSLY THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THIS JOB. IT IS MY STRONG HOPE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
MONITORING AND FOLLOWING AS
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE GET
INTEGRATED BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES SMALL AND LARGE.
THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO LEAD
SUCCESSFUL LIVES AND TO HAVE
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED SO. I DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD I AM GOING
TO ASK FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
DOCTOR FOR ONE MOMENT. BECAUSE
I HAVE TO COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THIS COMMITTEE AND ANOTHER SO I
AM GOING TO ASK OUR SECRETARY
TO GO DOWN THE ROLE OF OPEN.
ITEMS THAT NEED TO BE VOTED ON
BY MY SENATOR I'D TO MY LEFT
CENTER GROVE. AND MAN SECRETARY
WILL YOU GO THROUGH EACH ITEM
AND CALL THE ROLL. THERE'S A
POINTY NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR
ITEM NUMBER TWO PLEASE. GROWTH
I DROVE ALL RIGHT. FOR THAT
THAT IS OUT FOR- ZERO WITH US
SENATE DEBATES ABSENT. FROM
NUMBER THREE. BILL REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEES MINUS SB
SIXTY FIVE GROWTH. HI RALPH I.
SB SIXTY FIVE REFERENCE
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GROVE AND CAN I ASK A QUESTION
YES IS IT CAN I MAKE A COMMENT-
IT WASN'T ABLE TO TALK TO YOU
WITH ABOUT THIS BEFOREHAND OR
DO I JUST NEED TO VOTE ON IT GO
RIGHT AHEAD SENATOR WIENER. AND
SO. I HEARD THIS BILL IN MY
COMMITTEE AND I VOTED FOR IT
BECAUSE THE WAY I UNDERSTOOD
pPRESENTED AS THAT IT WOULD
ALLOW US SIXTY FIVE SIXTY TWO
DOLLARS FOR AND WOMEN THAT GOT
PREGNANT YEAH THEY WERE GETTING
BENEFITS AND IT WOULD HELP THEM
AND WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE EXTRA HELP AND THEN WHEN
IT WENT TO ADDED THAT COMMITTEE
REFERRED TO- ULTIMATES SERVICES
HUMAN SERVICES. AS THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PUT IN THERE AND IT WAS PULLED
BACK FROM RULES AND GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I GUESS MY
QUESTION ON PROCESS DESIGN
PROCESS- BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENT SHOULD
NOT GO BACK TO- HUMAN SERVICES-
AND THE COULD FIRST COMMITTEE
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WAS
HEALTH COMMITTEE YES. WHEN YOU
WERE ON HEALTH COMMITTEE WAS
FOR YES MA'AM- THE CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THAT BILL
CHOSE NOT TO- AB. CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE IN THE SENATE IS THAT
BILLS ARE ABLE TO BE HEARD.
THIS WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
THOSE VERY SAME AMENDMENTS. CAN
BE CONSIDERED. BY THE CHAIR OF
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND THAT INFORMATION WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE CHAIR OF THAT
COMMITTEE- FOR THE CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION. OKAY I'M- WE DID
HEAR THAT BILLING HEALTH THOUGH.
YES OKAY IT WAS DOUBLE REFERRED
VOTE I SEE IT WASN'T HEARD IT
WAS REFUSED TO BE REFERRED IN
AND HUMAN SERVICES OKAY I
APOLOGIZE OKAY I. GROVE. GROW
BY AN APOLOGIES MAN PRETEND
PERMISSION PRIOR TO COMING HERE
THAT'S FINE CENTER IT REALLY IS
SO ON THE PREVIOUS ITEM IT WAS
FOUR ZERO AS WELL REFERENCE OF
BILLS WITH SENATOR BATES ABSENT
ON THIS ONE ON IS FOUR ZERO-
AND THEN NEXT SELECT COMMITTEES
ITEM. ITEMS FOUR TO SEVEN. FIVE
OH SORRY I MOVE I WHAT IS-
THANK YOU SENATOR SO ALL OF
THAT HAVING BEEN CONDUCTED SO
THAT IF MEMBERS NEED TO COME
AND GO THEY CAN DO SO WITHOUT
FEAR OF MISSING. OUT ON THE
VOTE AND WITH MY DEEP
APPRECIATION DOCTOR FOR YOUR
PATIENTS WHAT WE WILL NOW DO IS
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR COD NOMINATION
AND CONFIRMATION AND I WILL
START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AND SEE IF THERE
ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE AND AGAIN AS I. SAY
THAT THE NUMBER FOR THE-
TELECONFERENCE IS ON OUR SCREEN.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. WITH THE
ACCESS CODE THREE TWO SIX SIX
ONE EIGHT EIGHT. N. I. C. NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE SO WE
WILL GO TO OUR- OVERFLOW AND
SECOND ROOM ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ARE APPROACHING THE DYESS IN
ROOM ONE TWELFTH SO WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO WELCOME AND
INTRODUCE OUR- MODERATOR ARE
WHO WILL JOIN US AND ENABLE US
TO BE PART OF THE
TELECONFERENCE. MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WE WILL GET STARTED.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE SHALL BE BACK TO YOU
IN A MOMENT. I WILL HAVE A SAY
HAVING HEARD FROM OUR WILL HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORTERS TO SPEAK. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OUR- OPPOSITION
COME BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND I STILL SEE NO
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I WILL LOOK
TO MY SCREEN AND ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I STILL SEE NO ONE ARE
PRESENT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SO MISTER MODERATOR I'M GONNA
COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU TO SEE
IF YOU CAN QUEUE UP. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION VIA TELECONFERENCE.
THANK YOU MADAM IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR YOUR JOB WAS
CLEARLY VERY EASY TODAY BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU- OKAY- WHAT I WILL DO IS
ASK MY COLLEAGUE IF HE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION. THAT
WOULD MOVE FOR THE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED AND I
WOULDN'T DO THAT WITH GREAT
CONFIDENCE BECAUSE THE COMMENTS
OF THE COLLEAGUES TO HAVE NOW
EXITED TO GO- PRESENT AND BE AT
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. WERE
POSITIVE TO THE NATURE THAT I
FEEL CERTAIN WE ARE GOING TO BE
IN GOOD SHAPE- AND THAT IS A
GOOD THING- THESE ARE NOT
ALWAYS SO EASY. DR BOLD SO I
WANT TO SAY IT'S PROBABLY A
TESTAMENT TO YOUR CHARACTER
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE AND THE
SUPPORT THAT IS. IS THERE. ARE
MADAM SECRETARY CAN I ASK YOU
TO CALL THE ROLL. I GROVE.
KAMLAGER LAYERED BY. AYE BATES
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE SO WE
HAVE TWO VOTES AND WE WILL
CLOSE OUT THE ROLE IN MY
COLLEAGUES COME BACK I FEEL
CERTAIN YOU CAN BREATHE A SIGH
OF RELIEF ACTUALLY LET ME ARE.
SINCE WE'VE HAD A SENATOR
RETURN LET ME ASK THE SECRETARY
OF SHE WILL. OPEN THE ROLL FOR
ONE MORE. VOTE TO BE CAST. WE
HAVE A MOTION US SENATOR CALM
WATER FROM- CENTER LAYERED OF
COURSE. KAMLAGER I AM LONGER I.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL KEEP THAT
ON CALL FOR SENATOR GROVE BUT
YOU HAVE THE VOTES TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD TO THE FULL SENATE SO
YOU HAVE OUR CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANKS FOR YOUR BEING WITH
US TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- OKAY WITH THAT- LET
ME JUST CONCLUDE- THE PUBLIC
PORTION OF TODAY'S AGENDA- I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS APPOINTMENT
TODAY. ODD TO ANYONE WHO MAY
HAVE WANTED TO TESTIFY BUT
DIDN'T I'D GET IN THE QUEUE IN
EITHER DIRECTION- YOU STILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO OUR RULES COMMITTEE.
TO VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS REALLY ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. AND
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW GO
INTO EXECUTIVES- NO WE HAVE TO
REMAIN ON CALL THANK YOU. AND
THAT IS WHY I HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE STAFF
SECRETARY. WE WILL ODD LEAVE-
ITEMS ON CALL AND- GO INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. MAYBE WE
RIGHT ACTUALLY YOU'RE RIGHT
THANK YOU- WE ARE SAVED BY THE
FOOT STEPS OF MY COLLEAGUE- IT
BEFORE WE BEFORE WE ADJOURN-
WELL BEFORE THE RULES COMMITTEE
GOES INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION
MINUTES SECRETARY WILL YOU OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THAT FINAL VOTE
FROM US SENATOR GROVE ON THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR BOWLS GROWTH.
GROWTH HI FOR THIS YEAR
WONDERFUL SO THAT IS EXCELLENT
THAT IS FOUR ZERO WITH A
SENATOR BATES BE AN ABSENT- SO
THAT REALLY DOES CONCLUDE OUR
RULES COMMITTEE OPEN SESSION WE
WILL NOW GO INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION THANK YOU.